création d'un observatoire du jeu en
france il s'agit d'observer comme son
nom l'indiqué d'aider les accros du jeu
une véritable pathologie les casinos qui
ont bien conscience du danger ont
d'ailleurs décidé d'aider ses véritables
cures de désintoxication comme on peut
en parler à propos de l'alcool ou encore
de la drogue laurence de leurs christian
en tant que joueur on sait jamais ce qui
va se passer au bon stop on stocke au
cas où le jeu nous emmène dans des
situations financières pas possible et
qu'on puisse pu nourrir les enfants
tout commence pourtant comme un conte de
fées la première fois qu hervé franchi
la porte d'un casino il empoche 15 mille
euros mais deux heures plus tard il est
déjà de retour le loisir devient très
vite une drogue
elie entraîne son épouse quand j'ai fait
de ma fille ben j'ai joué toute la nuit
jusqu'à 4 heures du matin pour ne pas
perdre pour surtout pas laisser d'argent
et d'un le je suis parti à 4 heures du
matin le directeur actuel m'a dit ne
plus revenir mais ce sont secoués pu
revenir puisque à 7h30 par un fake je
rentre à la clinique pour accoucher
pendant dix ans hervé va jouer quasiment
chaque jour et jusqu'à 6000 euros en une
soirée
c'est l'engrenage les emprunts la perte
de son emploi
les chèques sans provision
l'interdiction bancaire le joueur est
accro il est minuit vous n'avez plus
d'argent plus de possibilités et ben
vous réfléchissez alors vous essayez de
voir alors moi je vous dis j'ai moi ça
m'est arrivé de faire un aller-retour de
300 kilomètres pour aller pour les
récupérer un peu d'argent chez ma mère
pourquoi me pressent pour que je
continue
hervé est arrivé a décroché il ya deux
mois mais la plupart des joueurs
dépendants ont besoin d'une thérapie
pour cela le docteur valeur en reçoit
ici une centaine par an ils seraient au
moins cinq cent mille en france
c'est très souvent vécu comme un défaut
morales un défaut de volonté et trop peu
comme une pathologie donc léger rentrée
on n'en parlait de rapports récents
s'alarme de cette nouvelle dépendance
la cour des comptes note l'absence
d'étude sur les effets pathologiques du
jeu le sénateur françois trucy lui
souligne que la prise en charge des
joueurs en france est totalement
déficiente
va falloir contacter cette personne et
partir à mon avis sur sur l'interdiction
un tournant simplement de trois mois
dans un premier temps comme ici au
touquet certains dirigeants de casino
commencent à se soucier des joueurs
pathologiques
quitte à perdre des clients et ceci
après avoir fermé les yeux pendant de
longues années et son image leur usine à
rêves entraîne ses joueurs dans une
descente aux enfers il est le week-end
si vous voulez prendre le grand air sans
sortir de la ville salon nautique
direction donc la porte de versailles à
partir de demain c'est un des salons les
plus délicats les plus difficiles à
mettre en place étant donné l'importance
le volume de certains bateaux qui s'en
présentait julien beaumont jean paul
chaussée philippe dernier tour de vis à
quelques minutes de l'ouverture du salon
nautique
aujourd'hui la journée réservée aux
professionnels et sur les stands tout
est impeccable mais avant d'en arriver
là il aura fallu deux semaines
d'installation
alors qu'est-ce qui fait rêver
nous sommes à bord de l'un des 120
convoi exceptionnel en route vers la
capitale
il est minuit passé les camions poste
entrés dans paris et déjà les premiers
problèmes
ça ne passe pas il faut donc emprunter
l'itinéraire réservé aux très grands
bateaux comme ce catamaran
il mesure plus de 16 m et pèse 12 tonnes
un géant dans la ville alors pour qu'il
passe partout le bateau est sur vérins
hydrauliques de manière à le basculer
pour ne pas toucher les obstacles
et malgré cette précaution parfois c'est
une affaire de mm comme à ce croisement
non non ça va du moment qu on est guidé
une fois les bateaux arriver il faut
encore posé le mât au final beaucoup de
manutention ce qui fait du salon
nautique l'un des plus longs à mettre en
place
on occupe t elle doit porter ça et
depuis dix jours et certains des bateaux
sont partis à près d'un mois de leur
lieu de fabrication pour arriver à porte
de versailles
les premiers étaient là une semaine
avant qu'on ait les autres pour les
grands constructeurs un salon des tic
c'est un budget qui dépasse un million
deux cent mille euros en vaut la
chandelle c'est une vitrine / paris / /
pour jeannot et d'autre part c'est aussi
un salon de vente jusqu'au 15 décembre
on attend ici trois cent mille visiteurs
autant de clients potentiels
comme promis dans les titres la
perfection sur la piste à la pelouse de
reuilly c'est à paris la troupe
acrobatique du siècle de pékin tous les
superlatifs ne peuvent traduire la
qualité de ce spectacle construit ce pot
patrick des smicards
on les appelle les signes de lorient
dans la vie mesdames ou et monsieur wade
sont mariés depuis trois semaines
l'occasion de faire leur voyage de noces
à paris je ne les pousse certes mais ils
se connaissent depuis leur tendre
enfance
partageant les mêmes ambitions
aujourd'hui on peut vraiment parler de
vocation et pour tous les deux même si
au départ je me destinais plutôt à la
gymnastique
je vois de cet hydrogène
peut-on encore parler du contorsions
devant cette fillette caoutchouc
car le théâtre acrobatique est un art
séculaire en chine
surtout sur l'impulsion du trend line et
son initiative la création des cirques
d'état
à trop chine et occident on a une
conception très différente du s'y
rendent chez nous ça reste très
traditionnelle comme par exemple dans
numéro de la tra gold et bol mais dans
le cirque à l'occidentale c'est
résolument plus moderne où se trouvait
sur scène une cinquantaine d'artistes
pour la plupart originaires des banques
dont provinces du sud est de la chine
conjugue à la perfection faux simplicité
et réelle élégance et pour les 5500
spectateurs en tout cas un voyage dans
l'empiré du milieu qui s'imposent pour
cette année de la chine
dans un instant la météo c'est important
ce week end avec isabelle martinet le
point route avec valérie maurice toutes
les tous les détails sur les routes
praticables notamment dans le sud-est du
pays ce soir à 20 heures
béatrice schönberg et on se quitte sur
des images de la saint-nicolas qu'on
fêtera demain jour des cadeaux de noël
en fête au nord et l'est de la france
saint nicolas est également le patron
des écoliers et des bateliers bon week
end à lundi six mois si ici avec vous je
sais qu'on ne sait rien mais supérieurs
ont supposé que je
et où ce n'est pas toujours une partie
de plaisir pour l'inspecteur derrick
dans un instant
mais tu prends le temps de bien manger
quand même finalement tu l'as pas changé
d'autres acteurs